die Schornsteine von grammatosk früher
war sie eine wichtige Industriestadt vor
allem Maschinenbauunternehmen und die
Schmuckindustrie waren hier angesiedelt
jetzt ist sie eine der schlüsselstätte
im Osten der Ukraine im Kampf um den
dornbass die Heimat von alexander Iwanow
wurde schon kurz nach Beginn des
russischen Überfalls zum Ziel damals
Anfang April vergangenen Jahres starb
auch ein Mitarbeiter seiner
Hilfsorganisation tausende Menschen vor
allem Frauen und Kinder versuchten vor
den drohenden kämpfen aus der Region zu
flüchten eine russische Rakete schlug am
Bahnhof ein und tötete 57 Menschen heute
erinnert eine Steintafel an sie
die Menschen haben Stofftiere gebracht
für die Kinder die hier gestorben sind
ich denke das Russland einfach nur
Horror verbreiten will um uns Angst zu
machen und zu sagen wir können alles
machen was wir wollen
es gibt hier ja kein einziges
militärisches Objekt nur Zivilisten
viele Zivilisten und das wissen sie
bis heute wird grammathorst regelmäßig
mit Raketen beschossen Alexander Ivanov
hat deshalb seinen angelclub in eine
Hilfsorganisation umgewandelt die mit
vielen anderen zusammenarbeitet sie
wollen das Leid der Menschen vor allem
der Kinder lindern derzeit gibt es nur
Online-Unterricht die Kindergärten sind
geschlossen eine Psychologin kümmert
sich an diesem Nachmittag um die Mädchen
und Jungen es ist eine kleine Auszeit
vom schwierigen Alltag für Sie
ich versuche mit Hilfe der Kunsttherapie
heute hatten wir die märchentherapie die
Aufregung abzubauen den Stress und die
Depressionen
der Krieg bringt sie um wenn ich ehrlich
bin
psychologisch bringt er sie um
der 14-Jährige Bogdan erzählt dass er
sein früheres Leben vermisst und die
Freunde und Verwandten die geflohen sind
seine Familie will seine Urgroßmutter
nicht alleine lassen deshalb sind sie
geblieben aber seine neunjährige
Schwester Anna fürchtet sich vor den
Raketen
sie hat manchmal Angst wenn es laut wird
dann beruhigen wir sie
auch Alexanders eigene Familie leidet
unter dem Krieg seine Frau ist mit den
zwei Kindern kurz nach Kriegsbeginn nach
Deutschland geflohen seit einigen Wochen
leben sie wieder im ruhigeren Westen der
Ukraine er hat sie erst einmal zu
Weihnachten wieder gesehen
ich bleibe hier weil so viele Menschen
meine Hilfe brauchen jemand muss diese
Arbeit machen also mache ich sie
der russische Angriffskrieg zerreißt
Familien und bringt unfassbares Leid
über sie in grammatos ist der
allgegenwärtig Militärfahrzeuge und
Soldaten sind auf den Straßen unterwegs
aber auch der propaganda-krieg tobt in
grammatos Alexander zeigt uns den
Einschlag einer russischen Rakete hier
wollen die russischen Streitkräfte
angeblich 600 ukrainische Soldaten
getötet haben wofür es aber keinerlei
Anzeichen gibt sagt Alexander Russland
verkauft es als Vergeltungsschlag für
einen ähnlichen ukrainischen Angriff bei
dem Dutzende wenn nicht Hunderte
russische Soldaten getötet worden sind
es ist nicht das erste Mal sie haben
schon öfter behauptet etwas zerstört zu
haben etwa mehrfacher kitenwerfer vom
Typ Heimat in kramatosk aber am
Einschlagort war absolut nichts ich weiß
nicht vielleicht wollen sie nur ihren
Leuten zeigen wir haben Erfolg wir haben
eine große Armee aber das stimmt nicht
die Front bei bachmut und Solidar ist
eine rund 40 km von cramatosk entfernt
umso näher wir kommen desto lauter ist
das Grollen der Artillerie zu hören seit
Wochen tobt ihr ein sehr Stellungskampf
erzählt uns ein Sprecher der Armee nur
ein paar Kilometer von der Front
entfernt
die Kämpfe sind extrem heftig dazu
kommen noch die Wetterbedingungen unsere
Armee steht hier und draußen herrscht
Frost das Wetter spielt nicht mit es ist
kalt die Jungs frieren aber wir müssen
die Stellungen verteidigen wir müssen
die Feinde vernichten wir müssen sie
vernichten um frei zu sein damit sie
nicht weiter vorrücken Menschen
bedrohlich werden und was es bedeutet
wenn die russischen Truppen ganze
Landstriche besetzen das sieht Alexander
immer noch wenn er Hilfslieferungen in
Regionen außerhalb von kramatos bringt
dutzende Häuser in der Stadtwerke sind
durch die Kämpfe dem Erdboden
gleichgemacht worden den Menschen die
noch da sind fehlt es an vielen
mental ist es schwer weil alles zerstört
ist das sind aber Kleinigkeiten im
Vergleich zu dem was wir hier erlebt
haben
genau das soll sich in grammatosk nicht
wiederholen sagt Alexander auf große
Fried natürlich fürchten wir das wir
sehen ja was passieren kann
wir müssen unsere Armee unterstützen und
die ganze Welt bitten unser Militär zu
unterstützen
wir wollen die Zerstörung nicht sehen
das Familien alles verlieren
Alexander will seinen Teil mit der
Hilfsorganisation dazu beitragen und der
träumt davon dass dieser Albtraum der
Raketen Terror der Krieg möglichst bald
zu Ende ist
jetzt ist es so wenn es Abend wird dann
ist alles dunkel und es sind absolut
keine Menschen auf der Straße das ist
keine lebende Stadt ich möchte dass das
normale Leben nach kammertonk
zurückkehrt
im Frieden mit seiner Familie im Park
spazieren angeln gehen Fußballspielen
mehr braucht Alexander Ivanov eigentlich
nicht unglücklich zu sein